PROFESSOR: So now that we have
a fully parameterized safety
guideline for indoor
spaces to limit
the transmission
of COVID-19, we can
go through some case studies.
And I encourage you
to use the guideline,
in the form of the spreadsheet
or the online app which
are provided, to check out your
own space to see how you might
mitigate transmission there.
So here are two
representative examples
of great interest today.
So the first is a classroom
in the United States, which
is very relevant for discussions
about closing or reopening
or partially reopening our
schools during the pandemic.
And the second example will
be that of a nursing home,
which is a tragic situation
of great interest,
because a large fraction--
in fact, almost half--
of all deaths have occurred
in nursing homes and eldercare
facilities here in
the United States,
and a very significant
number around the world.
So first, let's look
at the classroom case.
So if we apply the
guideline, first of all,
we see the typical shape
of what is predicted
in a plot of occupancy
versus time, which
is a curve with roughly
a 1 over x type behavior,
because it is the product of
occupancy and time essentially
that are limited
by the guideline.
So you trade one for the other.
So we have here
curves representing
natural ventilation,
which we estimate
to be an air change time of
around 3 per hour-- or 0.3.
Excuse me-- so a
3-hour air change time,
and also mechanical ventilation,
in this case with 8 air changes
per hour, so reasonably
good mechanical ventilation,
which is the red curve--
the blue curve
being the natural.
And this is in a
typical classroom
space of 900 square feet
and 12-foot-high ceilings,
so for the United States.
And in such spaces,
the typical occupancy
might be around
20 or 25 students.
And so 20 students is
actually indicated here
as the normal occupancy
for this space.
And so what we see is
that the normal occupancy
is safe for a certain
amount of time.
But then eventually,
it becomes unsafe.
And so in the case of lower
ventilation, of course,
that transition
happens more-- sooner.
And if you have
better ventilation,
you can extend that time.
Also in the dotted line here
is shown the transient solution
in the guideline, which
accounts for the buildup
of infectious aerosols when
an infected person first
enters the space.
And you can see
in this case, that
buys you just a little
bit of extra time only
in the case of the
natural ventilation,
but really not much in the
case of mechanical ventilation,
where the transient and
steady state curve essentially
overlap.
We can also compare this
with some typical official
guidelines here in the United
States and also elsewhere.
So first, we have
the 6-foot rule.
And what we see is that
after a fairly short time,
the 6-foot rule becomes
inadequate in the case
of natural ventilation.
In the case of
mechanical ventilation,
still at some point, the
6-foot rule is unsafe.
However, before that
transition happens,
it's actually overkill.
So for enforcing
the 6-foot rule,
we are keeping people at
a fairly low density when
perhaps that's not necessary
for airborne transmission,
especially if masks
are being worn,
because that cuts down the
short-range transmission
and droplet transmission
that we've discussed.
And airborne transmission,
analyzed by the guideline,
is expected to be the
dominant mode of transmission.
So the way this
plot is made is also
allowing for rescaling
by the use of masks.
So and also, by--
so that's the horizontal axis.
So what is plotted here
is the mask-adjusted time,
which is pm squared times tau.
So pm is the masked
transmission factor.
So a very good mask
has pm near 0--
for example, maybe 0.05 or even
0.01 for a good surgical mask,
maybe 50% or 30% for a
decent cloth face covering.
And so that comes in squared.
And that factor
rescales the time.
So for example, we see
here with ventilation,
we might expect to get
40 hours in this case
with the 6-foot rule, or if
we're at normal occupancy,
maybe 20 hours.
But if we have good masks
that have pm squared maybe
on the order of 100, let's say,
or even 1,000-- so depending
on what that value is-- you
see you can turn that 20
hours into thousands of hours.
And so it actually becomes quite
safe to stay in that space.
Now, on the vertical axis, we
have the occupancy limit scaled
by epsilon, the risk tolerance.
So what's shown here, then,
is effectively risk tolerance
of 1, which we would not want.
We don't want any transmissions.
But if you reduce that to
epsilon of 0.1 or even 0.01,
then you again pick up
a factor of, let's say,
10 to 100 reduction in
the time or the occupancy.
But again, with masks, that's
offset by a factor which
is typically larger than that.
So what we're seeing
here is that even
in a very conservative
viewpoint,
if we analyze a
classroom space--
where there by the way is no
filtration or other mitigation
measures occurring
except for ventilation
at either of these rates--
we see that if masks
are worn consistently
that we should be able
to get tens or even
hundreds of hours of
shared use of that space,
even at normal occupancy.
Now, how should we
interpret that time?
So the time could be a
continuous occupancy time.
But especially if we're
looking at the steady state
value, which is
more conservative
than the transient,
then we can simply
add up the cumulative time
that people spend together
in the presence of
an infected person.
And so if we get
to a number like,
for example, 40 hours,
which we can easily
achieve wearing masks
with normal occupancy
and decent
ventilation, then that
might correspond to one
week in the classroom
with an infected person.
That's a very good number,
because the time to symptoms
is around five or six
days with COVID-19.
Now, of course, some
transitions may be symptomless.
But the recovery time is also
on the order of maybe two weeks.
And so if you can stay
during that period of time
in the presence of
an infected person,
that infected person
essentially will
be removed, either by
recovery or by showing
symptoms and hopefully removing
themselves and going home.
Also, this kind of analysis
can inform testing.
If the guideline
says that you're
safe for a week or even two
weeks of occupancy, given
the number of hours per day
and the other conditions,
and the testing frequency is,
let's say, once per week--
and also we know that the
most infectious time only
happens after, say, five
or six days after becoming
infected-- then with weekly
testing and mask use,
this becomes an
extremely safe situation
from the perspective of
airborne transmission
if people are wearing masks
carefully during that time.
So that's one way to think
about these guidelines.
Also, the guideline can tell you
the relative risk improvement
if you, say,
introduce filtration,
or you change the
humidity of the room
or change the ventilation rate
other than values shown here.
And you can play with the
spreadsheet or the online app
to see how those
changes can take place.
Our next example
is a nursing home.
Now, here, I've-- instead
of scaling to epsilon,
the risk tolerance, I've
just chosen a risk tolerance
of 0.01, which is a 1% risk
of transmission if an infected
person were to enter this space.
You may want to take even a
smaller value, to be even more
conservative, given
the grave danger
that persons who
are in nursing homes
are facing, partly
due to their age
and also due to the
common situation
of pre-existing conditions,
given that in many cases,
there may only be months
or years left of life
expectancy for those people.
And so they are, in fact, at
the highest risk for COVID-19.
So you want to pick
a very small epsilon.
And so now, if you
look at these curves,
then you see the horizontal
axis has now changed to minutes.
So that's if no one is
wearing a mask, then
on the order of minutes--
so something like
the 15-minute rule--
you can see there becomes
a risk of infection,
although ventilation can
help and can turn the 15
minutes, say, into 30 minutes.
If we look at, say,
the 6-foot rule,
which is shown here,
which would only
place two people in a
typical nursing home room
that we have just shown here--
so that would be two beds,
although in some cases, as
in the example shown here,
which is based on New
York City nursing homes,
the size of the space
that we've assumed here
would actually have a normal
maximum occupancy of three.
So there could even be
three beds in this space.
And the point is that even if
these beds are 6 feet apart,
if the people are
not wearing masks--
or if a person enters the
room, who is infected,
who is not wearing a mask--
the risk of transmission
is actually very high.
And if people spend
long periods of time
without masks, as many
nursing home patients must
do because they have
trouble breathing already--
so unless they're
on a respirator,
if they're just kind of
in relatively good shape,
they will be
breathing oftentimes
for long periods without masks.
And that can be
a serious problem
and lead to very high risk.
So the guideline
essentially helps
to sound the alarm for
those sorts of situations
and helps those facilities and
the caregivers design the space
and the time spent in the
space with different people
in a way that can help
to protect the residents,
and also when combined with
testing and other mitigation
measures, can hopefully reduce
the spread of the disease
where it matters the most and
has led to the most deaths.